returning to our top story now the
ceasefire extension in Sudan and joining
me to discuss this is Agnes oswaha
ambassador to Sudan's neighboring
country South Sudan thanks so much for
coming in to see us this morning uh the
ceasefire has been extended for another
72 hours what are you hearing about how
many more evacuations are going to be
possible in that time specifically for
for British Nationals thank you Sally
for having me here at this studio and
also giving a platform for the unfolding
crisis in the Republic of the Sudan
which is a dear neighbor and sisterly
country for the Republic of South Sudan
so the ceasefire is intended for
humanitarian access which include the
evacuation of foreign diplomats as well
as to give a chance to civilians who
wish to evacuate
and what is South Sudan's position in
this conflict there have been
suggestions that you might be holding
peace talks in Juba is that going to go
ahead yeah that will be going ahead so
president General salvacare has been
mandated by the egad to lead the
negotiations and he has been in close
contact
with the warring parties especially
chairman al-borhan as well as Deputy
chairman
jimeti who is a general Douglas and does
South Sudan have an affiliation with the
with either side
as you know as a lead negotiator uh the
main aspect here is to engage both and
to listen to both keenly so the goal uh
is to return both to the negotiation
table and to have the issues of Sudan to
be resolved in amicable manner without
leading to another loss of civilians or
creating a crisis through Sudan now
we've been focusing a lot this week
about on the evacuations of foreign
Nationals let's talk about the Sudanese
civilians trapped especially in Khartoum
uh the fighting's been going on for what
nearly two weeks now uh people are very
very desperate how bad have things got
uh the foreign Nationals evacuation so
for instance our neighbor Kenya has
evacuated its Nationals UK has done most
of the evacuation and is still ongoing
U.S has done Deva
South Sudan also we have refugees what
about the people left behind well this
is where I'm leading to yeah for example
we have refugees who are South sudanis
who reside in the Sudan and we have the
Sudanese citizens
so now they are fleeing most of them are
fleeing you see neighboring countries
yeah are you seeing a big influx of
people across your border into South
Sudan over ten thousand already reaching
and they're being evacuated to South
Sudan and can you cope with the numbers
of people arriving into South Sudan uh
we will be able to do so with the
support of the region and the
International Community but we're
willing to receive them they are our
brothers and sisters yeah I mean South
Sudan isn't without its own security
problems its own humanitarian issues can
you cope with this huge influx of
refugees and that's why I'm asking for
help yeah so that the development
Partners in South Sudan to be able to
increase
their support in order for us to meet
the demand for the refugees and what are
you hearing about uh Sudanese civilians
who are still trapped in Khartoum are
people starving people are starving and
with these uh ceasefires the succession
of hostilities it will give them a
chance to get some food and water
however there are those who are sick so
some of them might already died due to
lack of access to medical attention
how is the Healthcare System holding up
I've been hearing that it's on it's on
the verge of falling apart uh it is and
that's why we really hope the succession
of hostilities will continue so that the
International Community could respond
are you expecting a huge displacement of
people following this conflict
for us I mean for us as a government of
South Sudan we are hoping that this
situation could be contained as soon as
possible and not let it grow and to get
out of him is this going to be the next
big Refugee crisis do you think uh this
is what we are seeing but we are
we are hopeful that the two warring
parties will be able to pursue peace and
to put the interests of the Sudanese
population
in front of their personal interests
okay Agnes oswaha ambassador to the UK
from Saturday and we really appreciate
you joining us thank you for having me
thank you thank you thank you